okay today I'm going to talk to you
about hazards and risk so a Huzur diz
anything that could has a potential to
cause someone harm or damage and a risk
associate with the hazard is the
probability of someone being harmed if
they're exposed to that hazard so what
I'm going to do in this video is we're
going to talk through what each of these
six hazard symbols mean and I'm going to
show you how to do a risk assessment
so this first hazard symbol here means
oxidising now what that means is this
particular substance no matter what it
is
produces oxygen so it provides oxygen in
a reaction now as you may know oxygen is
is required in order for a combustion
reaction to occur so burning to happen
so if we have an oxidizing agent it
means that it could cause a flame to
burn much more readily an example of
this would be liquid oxygen
so these hazard symbols we find them all
of the different substances we work with
and it just tells us information about
that substance the first one being
oxidizing now this next one is
environmental environmental hazard now
all that means is it can be harmful to
all organisms remember the word organism
just means living thing so we've got to
be a little bit careful because
sometimes if we just for example tip
some substances down the sink without
dealing with them properly dispose of
them properly they could end up damaging
organisms in the environment an example
of this is mercury so each time in red
it shows what has it is in purple it
shows the harm that it causes and in
green it gives an example okay the next
one this kind of skull and crossbones
here that one there means toxic so if
you see that symbol on the side of the
bottle it means that it can cause death
now this could be through several
different means it could be depending on
the different substance it could be
caused by swallowing breathing in or in
certain cases absorption through the
skin itself an example of this a toxic
substance is hydrogen cyanide so it's
the one that can cause death just think
of the skull and crossbones is a nice
way of remembering that it causes death
okay next up this exclamation mark this
sign here means harmful okay so it can
basically cause irritation reddening or
blistering of the skin so if you spill
this chemical onto your hands these are
the different problems that it could
potentially cause an example of this
being bleach so if you are spill bleach
on your hands it could cause irritation
reddening and could also cause blisters
right next up we have this one the one
that looks like a fire just simply means
highly flammable now a highly flammable
substance is one that catches fire
easily so you want to keep this one way
away from an open flame because it can
catch fire really really readily really
easily an example would be petrol now
people often get these two symbols
confused highly flammable and oxidizing
the way that I remember which ones which
is if you have a look at oxidizing that
there that circle looks like an O bow
for oxidizing so that's the way that I
tell the difference between them highly
flammable means that substance itself
catches fire easily oxidizing means it
just produces and provides oxygen into
reaction which therefore causes more
burning or more combustion to occur this
one here is corrosive so what corrosive
means
is it destroys materials now as you can
see from the diagram this could be
materials as in material substances or
biological substances for example skin
so concentrated sulfuric acid
concentrated sulfuric acid is an example
of this if you get it on your skin it
can burn right through it could also
damage different materials as well
now what before we use any of these
substances in science we need to do
something called a risk assessment in a
risk assessment we look at a particular
substance to try and think about how we
can make sure we're not going to get
hurt when we use it so for example let's
imagine I was using this substance here
someone has it is soft uric acid that's
the thing which could harm me so the
hazard is the thing which could harm me
what harm can it cause so what it could
do to me is it could damage my skin and
my eyes if I'm not careful so the whole
point of risk assessment is to think
about what am I going to do to keep
myself safe the next thing I need to
think about is how likely is it that I
was going to get yourself uric acid on
my skin or in my eyes well I'd say
there's a kind of medium chance of this
happening it's quite easy to to have a
small spillage of a substance onto your
hands so what could I do in order to
help now this part here is the most
important part as you can see there's a
nice way of working way through risk
assessment because each stage begins
with age hazard harm how likely help so
this final stage is the really important
one considering the damage that could be
caused the harm that could be caused
from the hazard what can I do to make
sure I don't get harmed by this so what
I could do just prevent the damage of
the skin I could wear gloves to prevent
damage of my eyes I could wear goggles
and also I've got to try and use a low
concentration as possible because
obviously the lower the concentration
the less corrosive that this substance
is going to be so that is these are the
different hazards that we need to know
and this is how to complete a risk
assessment thank you very much